So how would you use the notion of understanding [UNKNOWN] frames, constraint,
and ambiguity to address Raven's progressive matrices? One example of
an application here, would be to the idea of multiple possible transformations,
that we saw in some of our earlier problems.
We saw certain problems that could be solved with either rotation or
a reflection, but they would give different answers. You might imagine a frame
that dictates certain expected values for different transformations. And
the degree of fit to those expectations can dictate the accuracy of that
particular answer. Try to think of the different phases of the understanding
process. How do you first understand what's happening in the problem?
How do you fit that, into a thematically role frame representation? And
how would that representation then help you transfer and solve the problem?